the Joe Rogan experience he made this
dope car well you nervous about beating
big J no let-up met him before he's
really nice he's always been nice I know
but he's like a comedy man at
Massachusetts comedy God another Tonight
Show and then now this car God he's like
two loves he does have that but man he
is so much more comfortable and like
happy nothing about cars yeah when he
was on The Tonight Show he's basically
like you know hey here's this guy pulls
out a gun and blows his brains out
Springs for man NBC Peacock yeah this is
a company man to the bitter end and he's
got an oozing his mouth he keeps
changing collapsed yeah the older guys
like Leno and Simon oh there's so much
more Zen now they don't have to
Instagram and all that [ __ ] they don't
care they'll podcast they don't do any
of this [ __ ] they don't do stories and
tweets and they seem like I've hung out
with some if I don't wanna say we're
buddies but I've hung out with him a few
times because of comedy and he's like
wise and he does TM you know and he
doesn't drink and he's like centered and
he's got a family and he loves comedy
and he's got his money and it's just
he's he's a good guy to look up to as a
as a comedian and like a business person
where you want to be and as a man where
you want to be in life and how you want
to be and what you want to be like mmm
like tonight have you heard about how I
met him no oh dude I mean he was my guy
like I was doing him when I started and
it was embarrassing did you do a guy
yeah I did Jenny okay
I caught myself on stage once going oh
yes exactly I did an open mic in New
York and in New York they were ruthless
and I went on so I was walking to the
mic and some kid in the back went and it
[ __ ] crushed me because he was
mocking me leveled me because he was
right and I after that ever since that
day I chewed him out on the mic but I
also changed my ways because it hit me
right to the core and so you know
whatever I'm doing I'm doing four sets
of the night and I run over to Gotham
and they go ahead slow down buddy you
know when you got four sets you got to
make those times so really it's like
dominoes you lose them all and I go hey
slow down Seinfeld so I go ah damn I
mean that's how jaded we are as comics
the biggest comic on the planet is on
I'm like ah [ __ ] I could sit down and
watch him but I'm like I got to make my
shows so they go don't worry I think
he's going short so he gets off and I
and they go you got to follow him when I
go [ __ ] and that's bathroom break for
most people you know Seinfeld is done
we're not gonna watch the next douche so
he's walking past me off stage I'm
walking on and I go you still got it and
he goes hey I like your stuff and he
just said that like in passing and I was
like oh my god like I figured he
wouldn't even acknowledge me you know
and I'm freaking out so now I go and
it's for Merrill Lynch or something it
was like a corporate kind of thing so
you had to be clean so I go up and I'm
I'm beaming from this Seinfeld
compliment then I just [ __ ] level the
room I just it's coming out of me it's
losing out of my eyeballs and I killed
and turns out he was watching so not
only did I have to go after him but I
had to be cleaned thank God I have like
eight minutes on school shootings at
aphelion midgets so like I had to be
clean and it went well and I got off and
so I was like oh that was fun let's go
to the next set he goes hey came out of
the shadows he goes let's go hang out so
I go oh my god and it was like a hot
lady you know when you have a good set
you got a little juice with her I would
never have anything to do with this lady
without comedy and we go in the
greenroom
we talk for an hour and a half I'm
[ __ ] myself for the first ten
minutes he's my here I grew up while
watching with my family
must-see TV NBC Thursday nights and
we're the first 10 minutes I'm [ __ ]
because you know you know this guy's
face you know his voice and everything
so well I know everything he's done I've
read his biographies and [ __ ] and then
after ten minutes is just a comic he's
just a Long Island car guy baseball guy
comedy guy and it was just super cool
and we talked and he goes take my number
and I go I'll never I'll never call he
goes use it use it and that was it we
just texted a little and then as he was
as I was leaving he did a bit that I was
new and I go hey I got a tag for you on
that cemetary bit and he goes I whatever
take it easy next day what he got in the
cemetery bit now we're texted so now I
did go write a bit
you know I had to write a bit in the
time you didn't really have anything not
that was [ __ ] with them so now I'm
writing a cemetery bit I'm like I'm
googling cemeteries and [ __ ] I don't
know anyone cemeteries so I came up some
headstone pun [ __ ] and I said it to
him and I could tell he was like yeah
that sucks blow me - they say I tried to
save it I wanted to keep it going it's
like talking on a supermodel right when
I was like but you don't wanna step on
Karlin cemetery bit and he goes wait
what's that so I sent him that clip and
now we're going back foot block Karlin
and then he and I go I think he's better
than prior and he goes what are you
crazy so now we're going on a Carl and
prior fight and we just [ __ ] had it
with two hours of texting it was amazing
why didn't just call each other you got
that conversation done you're also
watching TV I know he's 65 till he took
forever to get the words out but he's
glasses yeah but I didn't want to I
didn't want it to end I was happy was
long so yeah so now you're besties I
wouldn't say that but I'm getting close
I wouldn't I wouldn't even say pretty
close I'm closer to you than I am to him
you know it's one of them weird ones
yeah you don't want to bother and then I
get it and then you don't want to come
on too strong where he's like this guy
is up my ass cuz anything bothering that
guy exactly
[Applause]